jubilee reunimos a 7 escorpio dios soy
escorpio soy scordia soy escorpión soy
escorpio yo soy escorpio soy escorpión
soy escorpio uno de ellos miente si el
grupo descubre al mentiroso se
repartirán el premio
pero si el mentiroso sobrevive ganará
todo el premio
quién es el impostor el impostor
escorpio ronda quisieran decir cuando
nacieron y empiezo yo 6 y 7 de noviembre
14 de noviembre 28 de octubre cumplimos
el mismo día en serio y cuando me dijo
que cumplía el mismo día que yo pensé
interesante será verdad o mentira
primero de noviembre y 21 de noviembre
27 de octubre los han llamado
desagradables por cómo se ven si creo
que se debe al estereotipo de tener una
cara odiosa sabes si me han dicho cuando
te conocí me sentí súper intimidarlo y
los scorpions
sarcásticos su humor ese eco creativo
son personas bastante reservadas y muy
introvertida tienen tatuajes sí tengo
dos este y uno de escorpio amo mira el
tuyo
es un esqueleto con una cola de escorpio
y dice nunca confíes en los vivos porque
los escorpio no confían en nadie dice
que es escorpión y tiene un tatuaje de
escorpión incluso podría tener otro de
sus planetas en escorpio y por eso ese
tatuaje lo hice por beetlejuice saben
duda confíes en los vivos es mi película
favorita chacal a
los seguidores vota quien es el impostor
pero la más tímida del grupo
casi no hablo y eso me llamó la atención
y me pareció que él quería demostrar
quién era a toda costa
sentí que copiar el cumpleaños de
alguien más sería algo que el impostor
haría
[Música]
cuando dije que cumple años el mismo día
pensé neira estaba segura de que me
eliminaría hondo alguno de ustedes creen
la astrología o trabajo en esto sucedió
genial me ha interesado desde que era
pequeña y una cosa llevó a otra así que
sabes mucho sobre todos los signos
no porque hay signos que no me gustan y
no lo sé duda entiendo pero ya sabes lo
que dicen de los géminis cuando hice el
pregunto esto pensé
que dije no sé nada sobre otros signos
excepto el mío en una publicación
siempre busco escorpio claudio es el
signo más importante sería un está yo no
creo en la astrología así que sólo me
dejé llevar por como decían las cosas si
sonaban seguros eso me daba confianza
que es lo más escorpio que han hecho yo
que me la ropa de mi ex muy bien pero
fue gran cosa al menos no lo que más te
ha el pelo las llamas que a ella
creo que lo mas escorpio que he hecho ha
sido eliminar mis redes sociales y
desaparecer por un rey no puede ser yo
también lo hice
sienten que hay alguna característica de
escorpio que no tengan en mi caso dicen
que los escorpio son muy sexuales y todo
pero yo soy asexual así que creo que los
planetas no se alinearon para mí todo
sobre escorpio me describe a mí eso es
genial me parece que es más que normal
no tener todas las características de tu
signo pero él sigue insistiendo al
respecto así que bueno fue curioso creo
que soy igual que él creo que yo soy
bueno estudió teatro y la verdad todo
sobre el escenario me encanta soy
introvertido te gusta recibir atención
de esas cosas bueno solo estar en el
escenario lo que me ayuda a liberar mi
energía reprimida
cuando busque el papel vi dentro de la
caja y mi nombre estaba allí así que
supe de inmediato que ella fue quien lo
hizo por esa razón vote por ella fue que
te eligió si él dijo que tenía todas las
características de escorpio y eso me
pareció extraño
[Música]
hay un empate el empate fue entre erika
y chris no lo esperaba yo pensé oh bien
así que nadie me creyó eso significa que
haremos una segunda ronda de votos
qué tontería no sé si algo sobre mí les
hizo creer a ellos que no era escorpio o
que era el impostor pero lo cierto es
que fue muy honesto si piensan que
atraparon al impostor pueden terminar el
juego pero si la mayoría tiene dudas el
juego va a continuar y por favor
levanten la mano si quieren continuar
con el juego
a partir de ahora cada vez que voten por
alguien que no sea el impostor el valor
del premio se va a reducir
a bueno una vez trabajaba en un
restaurante y un compañero preguntó qué
signo eres y le dije eso y escorpio y
luego me miró y me dijo se nota tienes
esa mirada y yo no sé lo que quiso decir
los escorpio tienen una mirada
particular y cuando ves a alguien es
algo profundo si me ha pasado trabajo
con mi hermana y un día se acercó y me
dijo sabes cuando te veo luz es malvada
me parece que los demás saben que soy un
signo de agua para ellos piensan que soy
cáncer siempre me confunden con un
cáncer a un tauro pero tauro no es un
signo de agua sino de tierra no es
lógico mi compañero decía un escorpio es
como un cáncer con chaqueta de cuero y
eso me ha causado gracia hasta el día de
hoy consideran que su estilo refleja su
signo de alguna manera o no
porque se supone que los escorpio son
como misteriosos o algo más sí y yo soy
como la erykah badu del grupo han tenido
experiencias locas en fiestas en una
fiesta de hallowen estaba muy borracho y
quería calmarme estaba en casa de
alguien más así que fui al frente donde
no había nadie y me desmayé no yo no voy
a fiestas
tal vez sea cáncer o tauro y no escorpio
y solo finge que es uno o algo así en mi
opinión lo que dijo no tenía sentido
[Música]
ah
si todos creen que ya atraparon al
impostor pueden terminar el juego pero
si la mayoría tiene dudas el juego
continuará
o bien la mayoría no quiere continuar
así que el juego termina ahora
si las luces se vuelven verdes significa
que sacaron al impostor y ganaron si se
vuelven rojas significa que el impostor
sigue en el juego y ustedes pierden
[Música]
lo sabía
se los dije les dije que debíamos
continuar lo sabía y ustedes no yo misma
me traicione
que el scorpio falso dé un paso al
frente y se repele en
[Música]
yo tengo el peor signo del mundo géminis
cuando ella dijo eso me asusté pero
tengo una hermana escorpio así que trate
de invitar su personalidad
gracias natalia por dejarme ser tú el
día de hoy
[Risas]